[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far
greater than what divides us this
morning we learn about the power of
partnership meg oliver shows us how
an nypd detectives desire to help a
former colleague through unimaginable
tragedy
has turned into a platform to support
first responders
around the country
callie stocker was born august 31st 2017
just eight months later she was
diagnosed with alexander's disease
she had her first seizure at 11 months
old the rare nervous system disorder has
only affected 300 people in the last 80
years
berenith and jason are her parents she
never talked but she
communicated with her eyes with her
gestures with her smile
callie was hospitalized 40 times last
year
will you ever be able to get out of
medical debt i don't think so
i mean it was just stifling
the amount you know their medical bills
multiplied
we want them to know that we're here we
care jason is a new york city surgeon
his former nypd partner detective robert
garland
suggested a crowdfunding campaign but
the stalker family was worried about
potential online scammers
and i didn't really want to do that
because
i know that there would be so many
duplicates
right off the bat i said listen i'm
going to put pen to paper and we're
going to make something just for
for you guys so you get the help that
you guys deserve what started as a way
to help a friend in need
became a three-year project to develop
the fund the first
website garland's research discovered
that out of more than an estimated 50
000 campaigns online that focused on the
military
and first responders at least 3 percent
have duplicates so he partnered with a
system called
id dot me which helps securely verify
someone's identity including their job
as a first responder
it's the only crowd funding website
dedicated to those
on the front lines so when a donor comes
to a campaign
they know that the money is actually
going to a trusted source
so far they have more than 66 active
campaigns
that have raised more than 350 thousand
dollars
including one to help the lake charles
police department recover from hurricane
laura
22 employees lost everything they were
legitimately sleeping on the floor in
the squad room
that night because they had nowhere
nowhere else to go they're trying to
raise
100 thousand dollars to help their
officers buy furniture
and rebuild really re-energizes you
and definitely restores your faith and
folks out there
outside atlanta captain damien butler
set up a campaign
for the families of two colleagues who
recently died in a car accident
it shows that the community really do
care
and you see the response and the
outpouring love and in southern oregon
firefighters are using the site for help
rebuilding a pivotal fire station
lost in this summer's alameda fire
without the campaign
that just means that we're waiting that
much longer to be able to restore
vital vital services and equipment
that's all since the launch of fund the
first
in july five months after cali
passed away what does it mean to you
that cali's legacy
is going to live on through this site of
helping others
it's huge it means so much
that not just our lives were touched by
her but
that a lot of other people are going to
be a little girl's legacy
paying it forward one campaign at a time
for cbs this morning meg oliver new york
to see that i know you said earlier you
can use money well
we've given you some ideas here on this
show how to contribute cali's memory
lives on
it absolutely hard to lose a child and
it's hard
during this time of year but we're
sending out love to you